very cheeky guy okay very good
big purple lid but it was a nice try
because usually primos tricks it works
on you magnus it does usually work like
the only thing you can
can beat magnus is the the pre-movement
it's not the only way but it's one of
the better ways yes i would know i
wouldn't you would oh yes
i made three moves for years against
disguise
how what can i do here edie
strong and fast gm that's the well
besides magnus that's the best guy i've
eaten fully just in bullets yeah
nobody cares yeah
okay this is an extremely tricky
position by the way
oh yeah but on the surface it looks calm
no it doesn't actually all right maybe
maybe on
i don't know on what surface no i don't
know
i missed this
so tense
so tense okay let's exchange
exchange some more oh i didn't see this
ah
boys now
[Music]
i'm actually doing great
on the position
the question is can i be fast enough you
could take an a7 it didn't so i run i
run
i run
i run i run
i run
i run
i run
oh tricky tricky
tricky tricky
yes yes
[Music]
it's meant holy oh